- Hi, we'll have two
chicken nugget Happy Meals.
And, do you want the guy's
toy or the girl's toy?
- Um, what are the toy themes this month?
(bouncy, energetic hip hop music)
- Oh hi, yeah can I try
this mint chocolate chip?
That's really good.
Actually, can I try
this nutty coconut too?
Mmmmm.
What?
Oh, no.
No thank you.
I don't need to buy anything.
- Mom, what's my social security number?
Should I get a HMO or a P, PP--
- Will I die if I had a glass
of wine after taking NyQuil?
(phone beeping)
(bleeping)
- Scuba diver.
Screw diver, that, yeah.
(bouncy, energetic music)
- I don't need to shower.
- OK, step three, whisk.
Wait, what is whisk?
With the lid on top.
Yeah.
(fire alarm beeping)
Not a fire.
It's not a fire.
- How long can I stay on my
parent's health insurance?
(phone beeping)
Oh no.
That's next year.
- Damn, Sarah had a baby.
Ugh, but that kid does not look good.
(phone beeping)
- Why is everything so expensive?
- [Voiceover] I don't understand anything.
(bleeping)
- You, you stupid--
I'm gonna kick you in your
a-a-a-a-a-asss-strology.
Hey little Timmy.
Yeah hi, how's your mom?
But that cookies n' cream.
That was a keeper.